hey what is up guys I'm kV HD here and
welcome to the long-awaited setup tour
video so I did the set up to our project
video right before final exams and I'm
actually still wearing that no sleep
team bracelet so thanks to time loss and
crew that got us through finals
obviously but now that finals are over
and finished taking them actually I have
the time to put some of those papers
away and actually get my setup together
and actually start to put together more
videos so this is the room that a lot of
videos are almost videos really are shot
in and dreamt up and this is I guess an
overall tour of that setup so I'm gonna
start left to right since that's usually
how it goes and right off the bat you
have a four bank of Lights some
fluorescent lights here this is actually
so this is a pillow from throw boy
actually so this one these are both
throw boy pillows and this is in a
one-of-a-kind piece of art actually this
is a 24 by 24 inch solid metal frame
basically just and mallar
if you guys haven't already heard of him
I've shattered him out on Twitter a
couple of times make some awesome art
and that is one of his facets and it's
obviously the Deaf punk logo from RAM so
that is what that is and that's I'm
about to be hung on the wall next to
these other facets I have here so that's
pretty awesome
and this is this bookshelf which really
was what mostly got cleaned after final
exams so some textbooks from the last
semester some microfibers and cameras
that's the Canon c100 end the Panasonic
gh4 which I'm playing with a lot more
and as you might have noticed my videos
have been the last few except for this
one have been in 4k recently so I'll be
talking more about that in another video
and this here is the plaque that YouTube
sends when your YouTube channel hits a
hundred thousand subscribers I got that
a couple of months ago you're also
supposed to get one when you hit a
million subscribers but obviously this
one was more than a year late so I don't
know when that one will come but this is
a silver plaque and I obviously wouldn't
have this without you guys so I'm going
to thank you for that one
and that is a camera bag and actually
some business cards I think
valid to show you guys these after CES
but I never actually got to so boom
there is what the business card looks
like with the new logo and everything Oh
in the back of course that's really
where I was proud of that so anyway
that's the bookshelf pretty much the
most boring part so over here
package I need to ship some storage my
backpack which I happen to use every day
because I'm a student and actually I
haven't here my laptop which is the
13-inch retina MacBook Pro and has this
black decal on it which I've always had
on it since the first day I got it so
that's that where I sleep this is the
printer that I use which is this Epson
Artisan 730 again this is boring stuff
mostly for school this is my daily
tablet of choice it is the Nexus 10 and
I happen to really really want the next
version about to come out soon o'clock
that's not on right now and my wallet
which is a little thing I got from
Kickstarter would focus this is a sort
of a small Nexus ditched looking thing
doesn't want to focus that's okay I'm
shooting with the rx100 so it'll focus
when it wants to so this is the the
beginning of the desk setup part that a
lot of people are curious about so again
I want to go left to right because that
seems easiest here a lot of the video
gear I'm not going to like review
everything I talked about but if you
guys want to see maybe a more detailed
video of I guess how I shoot videos or
what I use for four different shots
something like that maybe leave a
comment of what you want to see or a
thumbs up if you ridged in that idea but
anyway this is a monopod I this is a
recently acquired monopod because the
one I was using before wasn't quite this
hefty but this is from Manfrotto and it
is a beast and it stands up by itself so
it has these little feet at the bottom
but this is the tripod I use it has a
Manfrotto 504 HD head on it and it has
carbon fiber sticks and it is quite a
beast so this is the little side table I
got from Amazon for about 50 bucks and
it's housing or holding a couple of
interesting things here so if I can get
this fall out the way this is a white
balance card
and it's a pretty simple but also kind
of underrated tool basically hold it up
to the camera and in post-production you
can match the whites to the white and
the blacks to the black and get all the
colors to match and I'm still learning
this kind of stuff but obviously this
isn't quite white balance perfectly
because that doesn't look perfectly
great does it no it does not this is the
slider that I use it's not a motorized
slider but it's kind of one of the
coolest things that I own and I'm really
happy about how well it works so it has
a 501 head I believe on it or a 502 HD
head for Manfredo but basically it's
carbon fiber sticks it's called the I
footage shark slider and it's counter
balanced so you can just move this
weight over here and your slides will be
perfectly smooth maybe not perfectly
smooth if it takes some getting used to
the way this this momentum works but
it's one of my favourite pieces of gear
I might even do a full separate review
of it but I love this thing again the
eye footage shark slider carbon rails
you can extend it to make it twice as
long it's awesome
and then this head also swivels here too
so this is the camera that I'm using so
you like I said the past couple of
videos you may have noticed have been 4k
right so this is the red scarlet it is
quite a beast of a camera and believe me
there's a lot that I don't know about
this camera already but I'm loving
shooting with it already on the front is
the Sigma 18 to 35 millimeter F one
point eight lens one of the old
favourites not old it's actually a a new
lens really but it's an awesome favor
for a lot of youtubers and I have a
backpack I'm Anton Bauer on the back
powering this guy and it is it's a beast
kind of hard to pick up but again that's
where these sticks come in handy and all
the Manfrotto stuff is really really
well clip for that and I'm just
beginning to get used to this but it's
an awesome camera and if you watch my
previous videos you'll see the sharpness
and the resolution and the colors look a
lot better so it's thanks to this guy
the notebooks that I've used in videos
and taking notes in from dwell those are
probably in a previous video you can
check out again I'll try to link as much
of this stuff below as I can but it's
going to become
hard because there's a ton of stuff
talking about in the video these are
some other ones as I use this is one is
so this Sigma lens here does not have
image stabilization so when I do need
image stabilization this is the 17 to 55
millimeter Canon F 2.8 and it does have
is if Tokina 1116 very wide angle lens I
used it in the iPhone 5s review and a
couple of other random shots the TV
video I did that was that lens and this
is a running gun lens this is this 70 to
200 millimeter F 2.8 a crazy beast of a
telephoto lens but it's awesome for
events when you need to get in there
close and these are two Phillips hue LED
bulbs so I'm going to get to the philips
hue stuff in a second here's a little
android figurine collection going on
here and some charging stuff i have back
here this is a blue lounge sumo holding
these cables I want to charge Google
glass I want to charge the Nexus 10 I
want to charge my iPad Mini retina and
iPhone 5s this is a giveaway coming up
soon and some drawers obviously these
aren't that interesting it's just kind
of what I have in here I mean it
calculator memory cards USB cable random
stuff like that unboxing knife but for
the most part it I mean there's phones
in here there are cables and video gear
and microphones and filters and
batteries and and stuff that's related
to what I do on my youtube channel so
that's basically what's on all these
drawers and then of course as a college
student notebooks right you need paper
to the left over here is a lot of the
accessories for the red stuff including
more storage since they take mini SSDs
is a little high hat tripod with a
Manfrotto head on it I use it for a lot
of the low shots that you see from down
here on this angle and I've taken the
slider out there that is because the
slider is on this I had tripod so there
you go fun fact now I'm gonna put this
back here so you may have noticed it's
it's not the cleanest desk in the world
I tend to say I'm kind of a minimal
person but definitely not be most
minimal so this is the
boy that I keep around the desk elided
c128 gig Wi-Fi iPad Mini retina and so
actually the thing I use in most for
here is the Philips hue app so but go
ahead and turn this red blue all the
lights in this room including that four
up here I just turned red and blue
because of the scheme I have turned on I
have a video setting which turns all of
them a bright white and on so that's
pretty cool so that's really that the
number one most used app on this iPad
but there's a ton of other stuff that I
use for basically watching videos and
catching up and Twitter and all that
kind of tablet fun stuff I surprisingly
don't gain very much this is the last
lens of choice this is the Sigma 18 to
35 millimeter F one point eight rehoused
cine style so it's D clipped aperture
ring here from F 1.8 to f-16 I have red
gaffer tape just because I like red and
it has a filter in front but no lens cap
so I keep it like that and that is the
Nexus 5's wireless charger for when I
actually charge the Nexus 5 so this is
the iPhone 5s like I said I carry a
couple phones at any given time you just
happen to be the two that are most used
right now this is the Google Play
edition HTC One m8 and the iPhone 5s in
black this is the Fuji x100s it's a
pretty boy camera I haven't talked a lot
about it but I kind of want to show it
more on video because it's a really
quietly awesome camera and it does a lot
of things really well so I'm probably
going to do a video about that sooner or
later I want to do also see you're going
to get a lot of sneak peeks of stuff I
want to do videos about this is a color
where Apple keyboard it's completely
black and it's next to a Magic Trackpad
connected to the Mac but yeah this is
completely black keyboard but other than
that it's just a regular applicable so
that's pretty sweet I have no idea what
this chair is no idea if you probably
find it at Staples but it's a chair so
it works this is the mouse I use the
Logitech performance MX and it's a
pretty popular mouse you've probably
already heard of it
just on this regular-looking mousepad so
these are the displays I use and all
people have asked about the stand that
the displays are on top of and that is
from ofc express ow
from ofc Express and they're made of
really just wood and they're painted
black and they're actually meant to hold
a TV but basically as since I have to
displace or I put them on top one on
each side and that works perfectly so
two displays or the Asus PQ 3 2 1 Q
displays their 3840 by 2160 their 4k
displays obviously they don't always
have nothing on them but when I do a
video there you go
Matt goes 10 just lets you swoop over to
the new spaces the studio monitors I
have are no longer sold actually but
they are Aiki audio m5o 5v2 studio
monitors 5 inch woofers 1 inch twitter
at the top um I'm a big fan of high
quality audio and whenever I can listen
to it I'm listening to them on this
coming from the focusrite scarlett 2i2
and that is the preamp that's where I
will record audio and that's where it'll
output audio to the speakers our studio
monitors whatever you want to call them
through this so that's pretty sweet and
I mentioned audio so I guess I'll go
right here to the audio rig section and
this is the well this is what shows up
underneath the camera doesn't actually
show on camera but it's right underneath
the frame whenever I'm talking to the
camera
it's the shotgun microphone the
Sennheiser MKH 416 and that's plugged
into XLR and this end of the XLR we
would go into the zoom h4n or into the
scarlett 2i2 when I'm recording audio
there's the Mac Pro that runs the show
right now it's on Mac OS 1010 9.2
because the tendo 9.3 update did not
play nice with the displays but that is
basically the surface of the desk right
there probably the most interesting part
and I got the most questions though this
is the artwork I have up here I don't
know what these are called I got these
from like a Bed Bath & Beyond when I was
first moving into this apartment and one
of them's a Paris one of them's of
London but I
I don't know what they're called so I
can see can Google image search to try
to find them but that's yeah that's the
surface of a desk and that's really what
the tour is all about right this is the
other side of the room I have these
again this light there's the other one
that's the closet
not too much important in there except
me of those boxes um but that's the
essence of the room tour probably the
easiest edit I will ever have because I
don't really have to cut very much video
to upload this to YouTube it'll just be
in 1080p as you guys have already seen
but yeah that's it guys if you have any
questions feel free to drop them in a
comment below I might do a separate
video about them this is by the way I
don't have a perfect cable management as
I wish I did there's a blue round cable
box here with gaffer tape and another
one here and another one down there but
this is the battery charging station so
the red vault batteries charge they're
the 5 D batteries charge they're the
c100 batteries charge the rechargeable
doublea's for my mouse and my keyboard
on anton bauer backpack batteries all
this stuff is a charging station
basically anyway that'll be it
giveaway coming soon much more stuff to
come stay tuned on Twitter if you want
to be first to hear about the giveaway
but this has been the mkbhd post final
exam 2014 setup tour thanks for watching
talk to you guys in the next one peace